- (Mark) All right. Tasha.
- Yes.
- Tasha, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- Watts.
- South Central, kind of? South of there?
- No, it's the black part of, uh
of the ghetto.
(Mark laughs)
- Yes it is.
- Yeah. Projects.
- Tell me about your childhood.
You had both your parents
when you were young?
- Off and on. I can
remember just off and on.
You know, but it was
the never the same one.
I mean, it was my father first.
Then as time progressed it was
other men in and out and
things of that nature.
- So you had different dads.
Your mom had different...
- Yeah, we had different
dads and stuff like that.
Yeah. A lot of them too.
- How would you describe your childhood?
- It was sad. You know, now that
I'm an adult and I can think about
certain things and certain scenarios
it was sad, 'cause I don't feel
like a child should have to go through
some of the things I
went through because...
From like, watching, like, animal programs
and things like that and when you
see like mama bears and certain
dogs and things like that
give birth and stuff,
they're very over protective and
they'll do anything and everything
you know, to protect their young, you know
and I didn't get that. Know what I mean,
I didn't understand back then
but when I think back
on it, it's kind of sad.
- What kind of stuff happened to you?
- Molestation, being taken around to um...
(coughs)
Being told I'm lying when I was
trying to bring my truth. But you know,
when you four, five or nine, ten, eleven,
you don't have the maturity to...
To explain or to orchestrate a
conversation where people can understand
where you really coming from or
what really happened. You just know
you was in pain and you
was in fear, you know.
So it was really really hard.
And then I was abducted once.
- By who?
- They couldn't find me. Nobody knows.
To this day, nobody knows.
You know what I mean, it's...
- How old were you?
- Like, four or five years old.
You know what I mean, and
I was tampered with. Um...
And from that time on, I always remembered
being...
tooken advantage of.
In some shape, form, or fashion.
If it wasn't physical, it was mental.
You know, if it wasn't mental, it was
just being isolated. You know what I mean,
so I wouldn't be able to tell people
or say something, you know what I mean.
'Cause these things, most of the things
that was happening to
me was happening to me
by family members and people that I knew.
You see what I'm saying?
- Mm-hmm.
- And back in those days,
see I'm 58 years old.
So back in them days, even when things,
horrible things, like, things like, like
that used to happen,
it was a family thing.
You didn't take it to the police.
You couldn't take it to school.
You know what I mean,
you just couldn't do it,
you know what I mean. They would
keep you indoors for two or three weeks
until the healing or the black eye
or the whatever kind of damage
that was done to you was down
and life went on, you know?
- And how were things
for you as a teenager?
- They were a little bit more interesting.
Because, um...
I noticed that I was real different,
I just didn't know what I was.
I thought I was the only one.
But my looks kind of, um...
It sounds like I'm conceited, but no,
but my looks kind of gave me, um...
A free pass for a lot of
things, you know what I mean?
And um...
- And you were dressing as
a male or female back then?
- Female. I was dressing
as a female back then.
Because I wasn't either or, you know
Like, I never was able to blend in
and be one, you know what I mean.
And, like, I said my looks...
It helped so when I did decide
to do the thing, and I don't know
what possessed me to say, you know,
I can do this, it worked for me.
And I remember bumping into a few
other people later on down the line
that were just like me, but they
weren't so lucky when it came to
the look. You know, you could tell
specifically what they were.
Me, the problem I had, you just
couldn't tell, period. Know what I mean,
but that became a problem too.
You know what I mean, so, um,
it was just really really
strange how things worked out.
And then as I got a little more older,
I became a little more manipulative,
you know what I mean. I started to,
"Well, shit, I can use
this to my advantage."
- You can make money with it.
- Not just make money, you know, just
not get the short end of
the stick all the time.
- Mm-hmm.
- So I don't have to tell nobody
but I can make you believe that I was
going to tell somebody, because I
became arrogant and I started to be
a little louder. More boisterous and
stuff like that. And you would do
what I needed you to do. So the same
thing they were doing to
me, I was doing to them.
But just in a different format.
To serve my purpose, you know what I mean.
So the pain was a little less.
You know, it was like...
I don't know, it was just weird.
I don't know what happened
or what moment it was
that I just started
"Well if you don't do it,
I'm gonna tell my daddy."
You know what I mean,
but I just got this spirit in me
all of a sudden. I'm not gonna let
nobody take advantage of me no more.
And that's when I
started becoming physical
with people, you know what I mean.
And then I realized, you
know, 'cause I was so tiny.
You know what I mean, I really
didn't have that much...
Strength, physical, but I knew
I could pick something up.
And when I would pick something up,
I would get them together.
It gave me a sense of power too almost,
know what I mean.
- Mm-hmm.
- And then at the same time, you still
was gonna give me something
afterwards, you know.
And that went on for years
and years and years, you know.
- And where has this
taken you as an adult?
- It took me to prison.
Took me to reform school.
Took me to group homes,
family treatment programs.
It kept me institutionalized until
I was about 25 years of age.
I kept me, you know,
locked up in mental wards
and you know, family treatment programs.
And I fought hard, you know. Because
by this time I had a backbone. And then
people started speaking out on what I was
because like I said in the free world,
nobody knew, but when I was in these
institutions, they knew
because of the name
and I had to be segregated with the guys
and so forth. So my problem became
with them now, you know what I mean?
And I fought long and hard, like
"How dare you", you know. I fought
and fought, so I stayed in trouble
in these institutions.
I stayed in the hole.
I stayed in the four points, where they
strapped me down. I stayed, um,
heavily medicated. You know, sedated.
And strapped down, and...
I don't know, it was pretty
weird how things worked out.
Because no child asks for that
kind of stuff, you know what I mean?
All I was trying to do was, um,
make a fucked up situation a little
lighter on me. And like I said,
I wasn't mature to understand how
to orchestrate that. But what I wasn't
gonna do, was I wasn't just gonna
lay down and take it.
You know what I mean?
I just couldn't do that no more.
Just be tooken advantage of, be told
"Sit over here", or "Be quiet".
And it got to the point
that I became so defiant
with everything that I became
my worst enemy, you know?
You know, then I got into the drug scene.
And that's when things
really really got bad.
You know?
- What drugs were you using?
- Back then we used to do this thing
called (unclear), we used
to pop pills in my day.
Then we used to do this
thing called "lovely".
It was this weed, almost like "Sherman",
but it was weed, we smoked that.
And then we would do the thing
that's called "crank". But it was
a recreational thing back in my day,
'cause the world was different then.
You know, like on Fridays and
Saturdays and Sundays, you know,
you run the streets
after a hard day's work
of doing what you're doing, And you do
a little "chooch", you do a little party,
you make a little money
and stuff like that.
And then, when Monday got back around,
life became back to normal, you know?
It didn't become, um, a daily thing until,
I'd say around the '90s,
when it was a thing
that you really knew what
addiction was, know what I mean.
'Cause now people are consuming
this stuff every day. And it's a need now.
So it wasn't just a party favor.
Just to have a nice time at the club
or to dance or, you know what I mean,
to go out and turn some tricks and stuff.
You know, and, with that being said,
you start to neglect yourself. So now
you right back to where you started.
So the same thing that
was happening to you
when you was young, you
learned how to get out of it.
When you became addicted, you start
doing the same thing to yourself
that these people were doing to you,
or life was doing to you.
You know what I mean?
So it's strange how things work.
It's really strange. I've always...
That was just funny to me. That's why
I always said, you know,
I became my worst enemy.
You know, because most of the things
I went through in the
last ten, fifteen years
that was really really horrible, um,
I did it to myself.
And I did it eyes open.
And didn't give a fuck. You know.
I've been through all that, you know,
whatever is whatever, you know.
'Cause in my time, you
just didn't live past
18, 19, 20. Transgender?
Oh, no. Especially if
they can tell you was a boy in a dress,
oh, they found you in a alley somewhere.
And it was very very very frequent
when I was growing up. Down here in
Hollywood, Long Beach, the Valley,
and stuff like that. It
was very very frequent
and getting around. I feel like the 90s,
the end of the 80s, stuff like that,
they started doing this silicone
type of treatment, so the ones that
didn't have that natural quality,
they would enhance it with this
silicone and these hormones and things
of that nature, you know what I mean.
Even though they still didn't quite
look like a woman. 'Cause to me,
they look like science projects today,
because it doesn't look natural.
You can always put your finger to it,
and even when they look nice, you like...
You know, they go at night time,
you know, so they can cover up the flaws
or the mistakes that was made doing that.
So it was kind of strange coming up,
watching the transformation.
- So sex work became part
of your life as well?
- It became part of my life, but...
I became real perceptive,
I watched everything
because I didn't get no schooling.
You see what I'm saying, I left home
at an early age and these institutions
and stuff like that, so I paid attention
to a lot of shit, so I memorized stuff.
So everything I did mostly was by memory,
you know what I mean.
And just that, you know,
when I seen these people doing these
injections and going through what
they was going through, I was just
uncomfortable with their look,
even if they looking nice, it was just...
I just always felt "I don't
want to be like that",
a science project, you know. And um...
I just stayed clear away from it.
And then fortunately,
you know like I said,
I just didn't have the problem
that most of them had. I
never grew hair on my face.
I didn't have to put on makeup
to look like a girl, I
just look like a girl.
And that was my biggest thing in life
I just want to be either or.
If I could've been a boy and passed,
that'd been fine with me too,
you know what I'm saying?
But unfortunately, I blended
better looking like a girl.
And it served my purpose, like I said.
I was illiterate, you know what I mean,
I left home when I was young.
- How far did you go to school?
- I didn't. Like I said, when I was in
third, fourth, sixth
grade, stuff like that,
I stayed in the office,
you know what I mean?
These, um...classes for
people who were slow learners.
And I would just sit
there and throw tantrums
and fight with the teachers and
fight with the students and stuff there,
so I really didn't do the
school thing, you know.
So I put all my energy into my look
at that time, when I was young.
And my look took me a long ways.
- You been in love before?
- Unfortunately, yes,
I've been in love before.
Yeah.
Love is kinda sad
to me, because
men don't love the way women love.
And when I say the way women love,
I consider myself a woman. I don't see
myself as transgender, transsexual,
none of that, because I came up in a
different era. I was always who I was.
Then later, then they
start putting labels on.
'Cause you only what
you answer to in life.
That's my belief. You know what I mean?
I don't, even when I worked the streets,
I didn't let gays suck my dick,
I didn't fuck them in their asses,
you know what I mean? One had to be
the dog and one had to be the cat.
It wasn't gonna be two
cats and two, it just,
that just wasn't my thing.
I got off on the fact that,
you know, I look like this,
I carried myself like this and
I'm gonna be just that and I'm not
going to compromise that. I fought too
long and hard. 'Cause I felt like I was
pushed there, you know. That was the only
tool that I had to survive
at that time, you know.
Yeah.
And it worked for me for a long time.
Then I got older and I got sick.
You know what I mean, I got real sick.
Had the brain aneurysm
and the heart attack
'cause I was born with a heart murmur
and stuff and doing the crystal,
shooting dope and stuff like that, and
later on down the years, you know,
when you not doing so well and
your look and your beauty is not
working or paying off like it used to
you know, now I'm starting to feel
like everybody else. You know,
I pride myself on not being like
anybody but me, you know? But now,
we're doing like everybody else doing.
Fuck an apartment, why get the rent?
You know what I mean, get a tent.
Know what I mean? Go in a hut, you know.
Turning tricks for $20 when I know I had
alcohol problem, I had a drug problem.
You know, $20 isn't gonna buy you no
pack of cigarettes in
a Cisco and some drugs.
How you gonna do that? That was
mathematically impossible.
But I pride myself on,
I always had a boundary.
I don't do what the normal people
do that's in certain
situations such as this.
Don't get me wrong, I'm not a angel.
I'm not saying I have never done
some fucked up shit to, um, to get over.
But it never made me feel good,
so I made a firm decision,
even at an early age,
there's just certain
things I just won't do
to justify, you know, my happiness.
You know what I mean? I'm not gonna
knock you upside your head and
take your wallet so I can put
some money in my pocket,
you know what I mean?
I'm just not gonna do it.
I'm gonna work for it.
And whatever we agree on,
that's what we gonna do and
that's what it's gonna be. I'm not
gonna set you up, you know. I'm not
gonna steal from a girlfriend 'cause
she lets me come in and sleep on her couch
for three days, and while she's at work
or doing her thing, her husband come in
and we in her bed fucking. There's just
certain things I just wouldn't do.
You know, and to this day, I pride myself
on that because I believe that all in all,
everything I been through in life,
I didn't let this shit
completely take over.
You know I didn't become the
complete demon, you know what I mean?
I just figure I was a fallen angel,
I had a boundary, I
always had a conscience,
and um, and I found out
that I was real simple.
When you live to be my
age, and from that time,
life is really simple.
We make life complicated.
You know what I mean, by this extra
baggage we pick up. We pick up all
this different baggage. I mean, we don't
mean to do it at the time, but we don't
know nothing from here to there.
These are things that we're learning.
But what we don't understand then,
when you get to here, you
done picked up baggage
and now you done developed all these
different characteristics
and personalities
and desires and these different
feelings and emotions and stuff like that.
But they're part you now.
You can't be like the judge and say
"Oh, jury, stricken that from the record."
The jury already heard what
was being said, you know?
You can't lie to self. I don't give a fuck
what nobody says, like they say, a drunk,
you will never hear a drunk tell a lie.
Everything come out a drunk's mouth
is the truth, you know. Can't lie to self.
- What regrets do you have in your life?
- Huh?
(sighs)
- The biggest regret that
I have in my life is um...
(exhales)
My mother, because um...
Even though they didn't understand
what I was back then and stuff like that,
my mother was for me.
Everybody I grew up with,
they didn't have mothers and fathers,
they was disowned, they was kicked out.
You know, I chose to leave.
You know what I mean.
My mother was always there for me.
I could always knock on her door.
When I get on that phone to call her,
I don't care what time of night it was,
or day it was, and I could even be
with several other transsexuals
in a hotel room, she would get up
off her ass and come out there
and bring the money to pay the rent
so we wouldn't have to be
out on the streets, you know?
And then she died on me, you know?
And that's my biggest regret is she died.
And I never ever to...I was never able
to really like, um...
Oh, that's the biggest regret, is my mom.
You know, I know people have to die
and stuff like that, but
it's just like "Damn"...
I could do no wrong in her eyes.
And she knew I was a mess.
She knew I was a fucking mess.
But she understood because she was
there from the beginning, you know.
And she always was a mother to me first.
She always was that,
and she had her issues.
Know what I mean, a lot
of shit I picked up,
I learned from her. And
she don't even know it.
But that was my mom, you know.
And she was always saying, "I'm not
gonna be here forever" and I'm like
"Go on with all that, old lady", you know.
And then she died, and I was like
"Oh my god". You know what I mean, like
who's gonna bury me? Certainly not this
(expletive) that I think I'm in love with.
You know what I mean? Or
my so-called girlfriend.
Know what I mean, they ain't gonna visit
me if I'm in the hospital so I can
get an operation. Who
gonna bury me? You know?
Who gonna say a eulogy for me, you know?
And so that's the thing
that I'm going through now.
These, um, thoughts of trying to...
Accept the things that I can and
cannot change and just make the
remaining years of my life, you know...
Not so difficult, you know what I mean?
'Cause like I said, I'm simple.
And life is simple. It's really simple.
Like somebody was talking about
my old car that I had. "Why would you get
that ugly car?" It's a old car,
just what I remembered growing up,
know what I mean? It runs like
a motherfucking spaceship. No, it's
not a BMW. It don't have rims. I don't
need Prada and Gucci,
you know what I mean?
I've never been caught up with the hype of
my desires, what the public likes.
You know, survey says
this is this, and this...
Fuck that.
I can go down and buy
me a $2 spandex outfit
put it on, get me some accessories,
and put it together and
look like a million bucks.
You know? And I was more content
with that then other shit. Put myself
out there, trying to live like
I'm the Joneses when I know I'm not.
Who am I lying to? Now you're really
overworking yourself, know what I mean?
And you don't get no rest.
So if you don't get no rest,
you're fucked up in the head mentally,
know what I mean, you going all through
these issues you going through,
you know what I'm saying, and then
you add that to the
element, it's just too much.
You get exhausted. You get so exhausted,
sometimes I be so exhausted,
I just be like "Fuck."
When can I rest? 'Cause I can never rest.
I have to do everything.
And there's nothing
wrong with that. But the thing is,
I never had a break from
it. Know what I mean,
everything has always been up and running,
the rat race, you know?
- Would you consider yourself happy?
- No, I don't consider myself happy.
I consider myself to be a little
bit more enlightened.
Like, I believe I think I know
what I want now. I don't how to
put it into words, but, I know
what I don't want and I know what
I'm not going back to.
That I know for a fact.
I'm just not going back to it.
I'd rather be dead than just go to...
Just to live like that anymore, or
to be somebody's punk in the trunk,
or, you know what I mean.
To be used and most of all,
I'm not gonna use myself.
Does that mean I'm an
angel, no it doesn't.
I still get high. I do it in moderation.
That don't make it any better,
but at least I'm more aware and
I have a little bit more control.
'Cause like I said, once I just
didn't give a fuck. And especially
after she died, it was like
whatever is whatever anyway.
I wasn't supposed to
live this long anyway.
58 years old? Who heard...it's unheard of!
You know what I mean?
It's just unheard of.
It really is unheard of. It's unheard of.
And it blows me away every day.
Every day I wake up, I be like
"Thank you God so much. Thank you so much.
I don't know what it is you see in me.
But I got to be here for a reason.
You have to have some favor."
You know, so when people start
talking shit and say what they saying,
I'll be like "I was created by
the Father, Son, and Holy Spirit"
and if God has favor on
me, fuck your opinion.
'Cause that's just what it is, an opinion.
For somebody that's trying to
live their life, you know what I mean?
And that's a sad thing, that most people
go through life living their life
through other people or paying
that much attention to
somebody that's like...
Life is short. Why do you give a fuck
about what I'm doing?
What my fetishes are.
What I like, what I dislike.
You don't even fucking know me.
But you put that much
energy into me like that,
it's a waste of time. It's just weird
how people do that.
- What's the most important
lesson you've learned?
- You reap what you sow.
That's the most important lesson
I think I've learned in life.
You reap what you sow.
I don't give a fuck what you do in life,
whether you're aware of it,
you do it intentionally,
or you just do some
shit because your young
and you don't know no better,
you're going to be put
in this position one day
maybe two or three times.
You're gonna know how that shit feels.
And it's not gonna feel pretty.
And then when you feel
that certain feeling,
it can either do one of two things to you.
It can make you evolve to the next level
where it'll make you set a boundary
about what you will and won't do no more.
Or it can send you over the edge,
one or the other. You know what I mean,
some people just say "Fuck it".
So you will reap what you sow.
I think that's the most important
lesson I've learned in life.
You don't get away with shit. Nothing.
Ain't no such thing as a perfect crime.
You know what I mean?
You don't get away with nothing.
If nobody ever find out in life
till the day you die, you go to sleep
it's right here. You know
what I mean, you can't.
You can't get away with
it, you know what I mean?
- Karma's a bitch.
- Yeah. You can't get away with it.
Your mind, when you look in that mirror,
it looks right back at you.
- All right, Tasha. Thank you so much
for sharing your story.
- Uh-huh.
- Very interesting.
- Thank you.
- Thank you very much.
- All right.